so donald trump had two events yesterday
in ohio
big crowds lots of virus flying around
and i want to focus in on the second
event here donald trump did one event at
dayton's airport
and then later drove about an hour north
to some other part of ohio and did an
event later on in the day
donald trump continues to just lie about
coronavirus coronavirus has now killed
more than 204 thousand people in the
united states it doesn't matter
trump insists he's done great we're
doing great and he actually has the
audacity to say
coronavirus affects virtually nobody
that's a quote 204 almost 205
000 dead americans trump says it affects
virtually nobody oh the disease we
didn't know it
now we know it affects elderly people
elderly people with heart problems and
other problems
if they have other problems that's what
it really affects that's it you know
in some states thousands of people
nobody young
below the age of 18 like nobody
they have a strong immune system who
knows you look at you
take your hat off to the young because i
have a hell of an immune system
but it affects virtually nobody it's a
it's an amazing thing by the way open
your schools everybody open your school
it affects virtually nobody can you
imagine imagine having lost
family members to coronavirus and
hearing trump say
it affects virtually nobody
two americans died of ebola and donald
trump called
for barack obama's resignation 204
000 americans have died of this virus
and trump is saying we get an a-plus
he said that to fox news earlier in the
day yesterday
and we are seeing the virus affect
virtually
nobody you decide whether this is
someone who's earned four more years
trump still struggling to just speak
english
still unable to pronounce ulysses s
grant
annie oakley william mckinley
and the amazing ulysses s grant that's
good
that's a sort of like a packaged section
of speech
that trump is using a lot where he just
lists american
historical figures the crowd actually
seems to like it and it's not surprising
if you see who
if you look at who's willing to be
crowded together for hours right now
given what's going on with the virus
it's not surprising that some of those
same people
react positively and cheer when trump
just names historical figures
trump then encouraging the crowd to
report
unsolicited mail-in ballots to
authorities
what if you're confused i'm confused
it's unclear what he's
actually asking people to do the great
state of ohio
so get your friends get your family
get your neighbors get your co-workers
get everybody
and get out and vote got to get out of
the world
and in your state in ohio early voting
has already begun
and don't wait and when you see them
cheating on the other side i don't say
if
when when you see them cheating with
those ballots
all of those unsolicited ballots those
millions of ballots you see them
anytime you do report them to the
authorities the authorities are waiting
and watching
report unsolicited ballots
sent to other people
and importantly to stay with the facts
and to stay with reality
ohio isn't sending unsolicited absentee
ballots
what ohio decided to do is to send out
ballot applications if you want an
absentee ballot
you fill out the application and you
send it in then you'll get a ballot
if you don't you're not going to get a
ballot plain and simple
then as part of the victimization tour
that continues donald trump continues to
whine and complain that nbc didn't talk
about his nobel prize nomination they
they instead covered the hurricane that
was ravaging
parts of the country take a look it's a
big deal for our country right
and she said oh that's good i said let's
turn on the evening news
let's watch it this is going to be a big
show tonight get ready
an nbc which is one of the most crooked
one of the worst newscasts
and i'm talking about normal nbc not
msdnc
msdnc is the worst but so i turned on
the nbc with lester holt another beauty
and they start with a hurricane and then
they went to something and something
else and
i'm saying first ladies is getting a
little embarrassing with 20 minutes into
a half hour show
they haven't mentioned the nobel peace
prize and then it went through the whole
show they never mentioned then i got
nominated for a second one they never
mentioned
trump actually seems to think that these
silly nominations
by right-wing politicians most recently
this right-wing politician from norway
nominated trump for a nobel peace prize
he thinks that's real news when there's
a hurricane ravaging people's homes and
lives
in different parts of the country it's
the epitome
of self-centeredness and narcissism that
has become
unfortunately commonplace in american
politics
and then for the second straight
election cycle
trump is campaigning on all the same
stuff he's campaigning on middle-income
tax cuts he's
campaigning on build a wall he's
president now why can't he do it now
take a look
that's got a seat it's got a seat in and
we have a lot of new things including
additional substantial middle-income tax
cuts and other tax cuts and
and tremendous regulation cuts and we're
finishing up with our military you know
we're
building space force the wall is going
incredibly
this is part of something we've been
covering for a little while now which is
trump is running like he's not the
president elect me and i'll do tax cuts
elect me and i'll do health care reform
i'll replace obamacare i'll build a wall
i'll fix the suburbs
i'll do enter you know whatever he's
been president for four
years why hasn't he done these things
already he controlled the house and
senate for the first two of those years
he's had the senate all four years we
need to reelect him to get him to do
anything it doesn't make sense
and then in barely concealed racism
donald trump says that if joe biden wins
biden as well as black senator cory
booker
are going to destroy the suburbs
you know i ended a regulation that will
destroy suburbia
if biden got in they will destroy
the suburbia we call it suburbia
of the world and we love it i know it
well westchester county
the suburban they sometimes i it's some
if you say suburban housewife you're in
deep trouble so what you do is you say
suburban women they love me you know why
they want security
and they don't want projects being right
next to their house that's okay
they don't want it and by the way that
includes minorities because
29 to 30 percent of the suburban
communities are
minorities and that includes them they
don't want that
they want safe communities they want
great communities they don't want to
have
they don't want to lose the american
dream it's very simple
i got rid of the regulation from
obama biden that was destroying
suburbia okay destroying it
and i think suburbia has got to wake up
because uh
if they get in you know who's in charge
you know who's in charge of the program
cory booker cory booker the crowd
doesn't have any idea what trump is
talking about
i can assure you it doesn't matter
they'll still cheer
sort of half-heartedly and one bonus
clip
from trump's earlier event where he was
in dayton ohio
trump tells just a never-ending story
it's five minutes long i'm only going to
play 40 seconds for you
trump goes on an incoherent
unintelligible story
about why steam power is better than
electric power for military ships
i can't make heads or tails out of this
but notice how the the crowd is silent
they don't have any idea what this guy's
talking about the admirals a lot i got a
lot of animals i like the admirals
i want to meet with the catapulters sir
what will you want to meet with the
catapulters for i want to find out why
the hell the catapulters don't work
so i went there and you know they did a
new system it's electric it's all
electric
so instead of steam which is simple and
great
powerful good and they know how it works
for years and years
they decide to go all electric now if
you take a little glass of water take
this glass of water you throw it on and
that's the end of that you bring
somebody in from mit how the hell do you
fix it
and we're dealing with the ocean and
rockets being shot at the ship and the
rough stuff right
but it wasn't working it went on it went
on
and on from there i'm not going to
subject you to all of it
but these events bizarre in every way
and in particular i said this yesterday
kindergarten and first grade teachers
they don't know how to get the whole
class to sit silently trump has figured
out how to do it with a crowd of a
thousand
he can get them to just be silent
almost still like not moving with these
bizarre non-sequitur stories
and we are going to see many more of
these rallies this week
leading up of course to the first
presidential debate next tuesday
i will be streaming live starting at 8
30 pm eastern time next tuesday
i would love it for you to watch the
debate with me
we will be live on youtube twitch and
facebook that's next week
in the meantime more coverage of these
whacked
rallies on our instagram page david
pakman show
and follow me on instagram david.pacman
to see a picture of the beautiful cake
that youtube sent me
for our 1 million subscriber milestone a
gigantic
cake they sent me a cake that would
normally feed 30 people
there's a picture of it on my instagram
david pakman quick break
back after this one of our sponsors
today is
monk pack keto granola bars and they are
giving you 20
off when you go to davidpakman.com
snack and use the coupon code pacman
you know a lot of these uh low carb
snack bars
have a reputation for not tasting great
but
i can tell you from trying these myself
that that is not the case with the monk
pack
keto granola bars they taste just as
good if not better
than the sugar-filled chewy granola bars
that many of us
love but these contain only one gram of
sugar
two net carbs only 140 calories they're
completely plant-based and gluten-free
great for anybody following a low-carb
diet
but also perfect for anybody like me
who's just trying to
reduce sugar intake which i think is a
good thing i've been working
on a box of these at home they're
delicious soft chewy texture
bunch of great flavors including peanut
butter coconut cocoa chip which is my
personal favorite
it's great for a quick breakfast a snack
in the afternoon
i have been loving these you can get to
their website by going to
davidpakman.com
snack the link is under this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman